let's say you're a lion here you are in
your home in Africa going on a hunt you
are magnificently equipped for your life
as a predator you've got long canine
teeth
huge claws a powerful stride amazing
agility plus the sense you're using here
an acute sense of hearing as a lion
you're a social animal you hunt with
your pride about the only flaw in your
hunting is stamina you have great
acceleration but you can't hunt your
prey for long distances that's why
you're doing what you're doing here
listening stalking trying to get close
the grasslands and brush around you give
you excellent cover however most of the
time your prey picks up your scent and
the hunt fails you move on
and sometimes the pride its paydirt
bringing down a wildebeest
here's where cooperation and competition
intermingle once the wildebeest is
stricken you and the entire pie pile on
every lion helps the kill but you
compete with every lion for a share of
the meat for a lion cub this is a
crucial test if the cub can't feed
itself
he'll star it must get its share right
here is when the abdomen of the
wildebeest is torn open the choicest
portions are now available and
competition is at its most fierce the
getting is good and you fight for your
fair share by the end of the meal you're
injured along with most of the pride you
don't really notice you know a full
stomach does then you back off letting
the younger Cubs get access to the
carcass now you and the rest of the
pride groom one another
[Music]
whatever bonds were bruised over the
feed are fixed up here as you mel lick
and make up